(dramatic orchestral music)
- What if I told you
a story about heart?
We all have a heart
and that heart needs
to be set free.
Imagine a bakery.
A man.
He's an all American hero.
Heisman Trophy winner,
he fought in World War Two.
And in Korea.
He was also in Vietnam.
Not the war, just
vacationing there one year.
Hardest working man
you've ever met.
Harder working than
any of his employees.
Try as they may they just
couldn't outwork him.
But some people
don't have a heart
and sometimes those
people are your son.
He was as foul
mouthed as they come.
Where you from lady?
That's where all the sluts
are from, am I right?
My (beep) smelled like a (beep)
I wouldn't (beep) me either.
Huh? (chuckles)
Me no speaka English. (chuckles)
I hope you all get AIDS.
What, you too stupid?
What, you guys don't
understand jokes?
Go Trump.
But like most pure geniuses
he was also a
degenerate party animal.
(snorting)
(rock music)
Then one day, he's
wasted, flips his car.
(car crashing)
He survives, but his
brain is damaged.
The father, however,
decides to still have him
come work at the bakery.
(upbeat music)
Then one day the father
gets a call from a doctor
who explains to him that
they can return his son
to his previous mental state
through the miracle of surgery.
However, in order to
perform this surgery
the father needs
to sign off on it
because the son can't
make decisions like that
in his current mental state.
So the father now has to decide.
Keep the son like he is, happy.
Or return him to who he was.
(chuckles)
What up, nimrods, I'm
back, you miss me?
Yeah, I was a
vegetable for a while
you know what I mean?
I was a cucumber.
No, I'm kidding,
I was a zucchini.
- Oh, my God, oh, my God, boo!
- [Comedian] I was a squash,
did I already say that?
- Boo, you suck.
- [Comedian] Because
once again he's a hero.
- Yeah, that's a really
great movie idea.
So did you want a
cappuccino or a macchiato?
- Uh, tap water.